こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
皆さんSNOWというアプリご存知でしょうか
あのね、すげー流行ていうか大流行しております
僕もですね一回借りてやったんですよ
カシャッってこう犬のやつを
僕、昔twitterでつぶやいたら
すっげーリツイートされました
いやなんかねすごい可愛く撮れるんすよね
ちょっとやってみるよとりあえず
イケメンだな～
はい　というわけでこちらが画面になっております
基本的にはそんな変わんないんですけども
これでいきますよ
こうなんか色々できるんすよ
あっ出た
これだ！
出ましたこれです
これはもうね
かわいい
自分で可愛いとか言ったらやばい人だなｗ
こういう感じですね
じゃあ一枚撮ってみましょう
このさ自撮りしてる時の自分の顔いやなんすよね～
上目遣いで
あ、来たんじゃないっすか？
こういう感じでですね
えっとSNOWは写真撮るだけじゃなくて
送れます
可愛い？
絶対なんか撮ってやがる
お、来た来た来た
・・・
はい　という感じでですね
実はSNOWはですね
写真とか動画を撮るだけじゃなくて
メッセージのやり取りができます
謝ってきた
許す！
という感じなんですけども
今回ちょっとSNOWを使って色んな写真動画を撮ってみましょうというシンプルな動画でございます
いやめちゃくちゃ面白いんすよ
もうめちゃくちゃやってみるね
まぁ、犬はこれが多分一番人気なのかな？
まあこんなのもありますし
鹿
なんか完全にオネエだな
熊
熊可愛いな
あー舌が出るのね
口を開けると舌が出る
どことなくアバンティーズのえいじ君に似てますね
ワーーッこれさっきのやつだ
あ、これ可愛い
こいつはまたあざとい写真だな
こういう写真がですねtwitterですごい流行ってるんすよ
あー可愛い
俺さあんまり自撮り好きじゃないんすよね
自撮り好きじゃない僕でもこんだけ楽しめるってすごいっすよ
あ、可愛い
可愛らしい
送ってあげよう
ていう感じでですね送り合うっていう楽しさもあります
ｲﾋ ＃％＆（’’）＄＃’＆＆（’）
すごいものさしがあったんだ
あっちの村にすごいものさしがあったんだ
はいというわけですねこのようにSNOWを使えば様々な顔で遊ぶことができます
はいというわけでここからでございます
スタンプとかも面白いんですけども
僕はこのね画像を使うのが一番面白いと思っております
さあさあさあ上がってきたぞ
中々いいメンツじゃあないか
じゃあまずはですね
例のトミトミと合体してみましょうか
この漫画のトミックさんの顔が合体すると
ちょっと待って＊笑い＊
めちゃくちゃやんけｗ
こっちかな
おお！なんか惜しいｗ
なにこれちょっと待ってｗ
なんか違うなぁ～
これは？
あ、俺は俺なんだ
すごい　自分と合体しても自分のままっすね
アプリのトミックさんと合体してみます
これは結構普通に合体できたね
どうも～トミトミJで～す
すごっ！
こんなんなるんすよ
じゃあ次サンダーさんです　ごめんなさいサンダーさん勝手にやっちゃって
よーーし俺だーーっ！
カードキングダムのサンダーだー
カード欲しいカード欲しい
はいという感じでですね
スタンプ以外にもですね
自分が持ってる顔の写真とか他の人の顔の写真とかで
合成させることもできます
フェイスコピーを使えば多分
何人かがいると皆で同じ顔を共有できる
ここら辺はね多分僕一人だとできないんですけど
皆でやるととても面白いと思います
wwwwwww
はずい！（恥ずかしい）
はいというわけでいかがだったでしょうかSNOW
こういう感じでですね
こんな厳ついお兄さんでも
あっという間にニャン子ちゃんになれます
可愛い！
俺さまじ自分で恥ずかしいとかさ’＆＄＆＆（）％
アアアアアアアアア(｀艸´；)
おええええ
はいという訳でこんな感じで可愛い自分が撮れたりしますSNOW
なんか気になって仕方がない
是非皆さんSNOW　可愛いんでやってみてください
じゃあな
check out the next video too!!!share on SNS
はいというわけで顔入れ替える相手が来てくれたので
ちょっと顔入れ替えてみましょう
wwwwwww
俺の髪型をdisってるみたい（笑）
（聞き取れない）
顔変えるとこんな感じになってしまいます
で、ですねボタンを長押しすると動画が撮れます
ｵwgﾌｵｲfｸﾞﾋhｹﾞｳｲﾁﾞｴdhﾌｨhｳﾞｨﾌvshﾌﾞｲs
こういう感じで動画も撮れるんですけども
撮った動画は誰かに送ることができます